vous êtes notre invité donc on n'a pas
voulu vous mettre en difficulté vous
allez faire une émission littéraire
d'accord j'ai pas de compte en mois
allez on y va
bonsoir et bienvenue dans votre
patrimoine là il y avait l'air d'être où
il faudra y compléter mais déjà c'est
une émission était un peu je me mettais
des trous d'achat au québec bonjour et
bienvenue dans votre émission préférée
littéraire la toute petite
nous pénétrons avec malice la
transcendance est ce qu on peut juste
avait des lettres pour voir si elle
arrive à chiffres et des lettres est
grave
fabrice santoro les siennes allez c'est
bon de relire de ce chenapan de
chateaubriand et ses fameuses mémoire
d'où d'autres tombent mais je l'avais en
plus ça fait vite un programme faisant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
remarquer faisant les beaux mecs c'est
beau c'est comme ça il faut pas le dire
consacrons le tématé alex socialisme à
travers ces deux figures majeures
jean pierre pernaut non non c'est trop
compliqué s'inspire du ring au
socialisme s'inspire de la sénologie
mais il ne faut pas nier
bien sûr l'apport de la philosophie de
dunkerque car qu'hubert oeuvres clés
sont les mains
[Musique]
pourquoi on tue son
on n'était pas bien on gagne on est à
salles non c'est bon continuer bon alors
que jacques que c'était bien des gens
d'ailleurs ne dit-on pas que la
conscience est en réalité une conscience
de conscience car pour être conscience
du monde la conscience de l'être
conscience d'elle-même resta sur la cage
aux fauves est arrêtée là c'est juste la
france elle attend ou comme on dit en
latin
fluctuat nec mergitur le pq mme des
mouchards merci
[Applaudissements]